merci d'être avec nous sur rt france en
tant que gilet jaune comment est ce que
vous avez accueilli ce matin cette
sortie d' emmanuel macron à moins d'un
an de la présidentielle coûte comme ou
analyse fondée il ya un petit peu
d'analystes d'odeur mais c'est avant
tout un coup de com c'est du grand macro
on est habitué depuis le début il a un
culot incroyable que le reprendre sur à
peu près tout ce qu'il a dit après
l'épisode ridicule de mcfly et carlito
la parole présidentielle qui devrait se
faire un peu plus rare puis on sent
préserve mieux on se porte en tout cas
c'est mon avis cette histoire de
violence évidemment c'est sa position
préférée de tout axer sur la violence il
a pas tort quand il dit que le mouvement
de gilet jaune s'inscrit dans une
tradition de jacquerie c'est vrai que
c'est une révolte de type jacquerie
fiscale mais qui va chercher ses motifs
vraiment dans le profondeur de la
société
c'est une violence qui a pu répondre à
une violence préexistantes qui était la
violence sociale et notamment la
violence du discours d' emmanuel macron
quand il dit qu'il n'a pas été
réellement surpris par ce qui lui est
arrivé pourquoi dans les mois qui ont
précédé nous at il traité de tous les
noms
pourquoi at il donné des noms d'oiseaux
plusieurs catégories populaires
françaises s'il savait qu'il y avait ce
potentiel de sous-vêtements et de
violences dans la société
donc après il ya différents types de
violence lui lax sur sur les black
blocks qui en sont bien évidemment qui
préexistait au gilet jaune qui sont
apparus dans les mouvements
contestataires antimondialistes de ja
gêne ou à seattle au début des années
2000 mais ça c'est un type de violence
qui est venue se greffer au gilet jaune
la violence quand il dit on a
redécouvert la violence il y avait de la
violence quand même on peut pas le nier
la de triomphe saccagé des voitures
brûlées des vitrines détruites alors si
on veut se souvenir de la chronologie
il n'y a pas eu de violences au 17
novembre et les violences policières ont
commencé à se déchaîner dès le 24
novembre et à partir du 1er décembre
effectivement l'épisode de l'arc de tri
ouf là on a déchaîné un certain nombre
de passions des gens qui étaient
pacifiques lors des actes 1 et 2 sont
devenus clairement des adeptes de la
confrontation plus musclée quand ils ont
vu le traitement qui était réservé aux
manifestants pacifiques
vous avez vous avez utilisé le mot
jacques rey un cac à utiliser également
emmanuel macron dans son interview à
zadig vous êtes passionné d'histoire
quand le président dit que la pandémie
de comics 19 lui rappelle des temps je
citerai moyen-âgeux les grandes
jacquerie donc les grandes épidémies et
les grandes peurs comparer des
jacqueries sont des révoltes paysannes
de la période révolutionnaire au
moyen-âge la sk pas un anachronisme
alors les jacqueries sont bien
antérieurs à la période révolutionnaire
française on en trouve plusieurs siècles
on peut même remonter jusqu'au 12ème
siècle
donc ce c'est un phénomène particulier
qui est d'ailleurs pas typiquement
français après c'est lui qu'il sort lala
qui qui qui poursuit la métaphore
médiévale c'est peut-être parce qu'il a
fait un traitement médiévale du coc vide
un traitement même obscurantistes
dernière ferme en cuir monde en
enfermant tout le monde en confinant
tout le monde au mépris de la science
puisque julien tous les pays ont fait ça
alors vous pourrez peut-être noté avec
moi que la dégénérescence des classes
dirigeantes de tout l'occident depuis
quelques dizaines d'années et générale
il ya peu de pays qui font exception
hélas et on a trouvé les meilleurs
exemples de gestion va dire rationnelle
du phénomène de qu'ovide dans les pays
d'asie taiwan corée
même la chine ou le génial ma mère se
dit quand même très confiant un c'est
son terme très confiant pour l'avenir
selon vous quel quel avenir
après donc les gilet jaune
après le corps d'un virus mais y
aura-t-il un avenir après le court aux
navires us c'est ça la question il est
parti pour enjamber l'élection de 2022
ça peut durer et très longtemps cette
histoire partir du moment où il ya des
variants où il ya une saisonnalité dans
le virus si on garde le même degré de de
traumatisme social à chaque nouvelle
vague
si on remet des mesures absurdes de type
confinement ou couvre-feu à chaque
résurgence de l'épidémie de celle là ou
de n'importe laquelle on ne va jamais
sortir de l'état d'urgence et on sera
dans l'état d'exception permanent a été
théorisée ces dernières décennies ces
dernières années particulièrement par
les philosophes comme agamben qui disait
que c'était la pente naturelle en fait
de nos supposés démocraties occidentales
de devenir petit à petit les
totalitarismes tard notamment la
biopolitique c'est à dire la contrôler
le contrôle du corps en ce moment
pardonnez moi pour revenir sur sur les
gilet jaune et sur les déclarations des
d'emmanuel l'inconscient légine et jaune
il en est où le mouvement exactement
est-ce qu'il peut renaître est ce qu'il
ya des dates de manifestations prévues
par exemple alors il ya deux manières
d'études et jaune on peut être gilet
jaune en allant manifester dans la rue
et on peut être remanié gilet jaune en
participant à toutes les initiatives à
tous les groupes qui se sont formés et
qui font des choses très très bien
évidemment les deux possibilités sont
pas exclues en on peut faire on peut
tout à fait faire les deux mais il ya
des projets en cours
moi par exemple j'appartiens ouf je suis
déléguée générale du louvre nacré avec
des gilets jaunes à 1 contre
gouvernement complet avec des ministres
qui sont des experts et les comités
citoyens qui travaillent à un programme
avec d'autres groupes ont ses alliés
pour faire un programme commun
on travaille à une candidature à
l'élection présidentielle donc en fait
ça peut-être que ça va surprendre macro
des citoyens arrivent à se hisser au
niveau des politiques en matière de
sérieux voire de les dépasser carrément
vu le niveau qui a beaucoup baissé ces
dernières années de nos dirigeants est
donc ça dans les semaines et les mois à
venir vous allez en entendre parler à la
seule initiative dans son regroupement
est une tendance assez coûteux qu'il ya
un an ou deux
il ya certes beaucoup plus merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes entrepreneur et yvette auteur
de nombreux ouvrages notamment vers la
révolution en parution libre sur le site
éponyme et journal d'un gilet jaune aux
éditions jean cyrille godfroid